do blind people have heightened senses
what a blind people see when they dream
can blind people work of course we can
work I'm Lucia druid my name's Simon
Braille my name is dr. Emma Patel and
I'm totally blind and I'm registered to
the elevation impaired and I'm severely
sight impaired there's all sorts of
questions floating around the internet
so let's Lydia do blind people are care
about their appearance yes yes yes we do
just because we can't see ourselves in a
mirror doesn't mean we don't want to
feel good and look good I actually wrote
the first ever blind beauty guide
absolutely with me then I love shopping
I love going out and shopping for myself
so I rely on people in the shops to tell
me and describe things to me I'm
obsessed with makeup it's part of me
it's part of Lucy just because I went
blind doesn't mean I lost Lucy I
definitely take pride in how I look
have you always been blind I lost my
sight in 2006 I was in operations in
Iraq and I was shot in the head by a
sniper it ripped the optic nerves off my
left eye and there was catastrophic
compression damage to the right eye age
8 I went for a routine I checked with my
parents and they said quick Russia to
the hospital your little girl has
something wrong with the back of our eye
age 11 I lost my right eye and age 17 I
lost my left eye and now I only have a
bit of light perception do blind people
have heightened senses no sense can
actually improve what happened is you
get better at using the other senses I
learned to tune into my hearing a little
bit more focus on what I needed to hear
same of touch I can understand why
people might think we have supersonic
hearing but no unfortunately I wish
what do blind people see when they dream
now personally I don't see anything I
just have thoughts when I dream vivid
dreams I lost my sight save a night so I
saw my wife in the evening next morning
I woke up I was completely blind so I
kind of hold into that memory I see my
wife and myself having dinner a lot of
the time do all blind people have Guide
Dogs and how do the dogs know where to
go
not all blind people have guide dogs but
this one does and how do you work older
if kicad my guidebook hasn't ever been
to a location she will never know where
it is so guide dogs are taught to go
from curb to curb that means avoiding
obstacles bit lamppost bins people on
the streets and then there wait for
directions at left right across the road
I think the most common question for me
is is your guide dog a sat-nav and way
answer is no should I help a blind
person on the streets if you see someone
struggling whether they're blind or not
then I think there's an obligation for
those of us who can to support and ask
if they need support there is a problem
when it comes to crossing the road and
just being taken a good way to get a
blind person tension is with the back of
your hand on the upper arm because it's
non-aggressive place a torch somebody
introduce yourself ask them if they need
support but what I would also say don't
be offended if they say no and you never
know that that tiny about two minutes
out of your life will make such a
difference or someone like me what is
the question you wished people asked you
how do I help someone who's been
visually impaired that's probably a
question that would probably make my
life a lot easier
don't be ashamed to ask what happened
don't be ashamed to ask what's it like
there's so many different questions that
I would be happy to answer if people
were happy to ask sometimes it would be
nice to see the person behind the dog
and say hi Lucy how are you it would
make me smile
yeah thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon